[Music]
>> Hi, my name is Katja.
I'm a researcher in the Machine
Intelligence Group at MSR
Cambridge.
I'm presenting Project Malmo.
Project Malmo is an AI
experimentation platform that is
open sourced and that my team
built on top of the game
Minecraft to make it as easy as
possible to develop and
experiment with agents that are
embodied within the game
Minecraft.
We see Project Malmo as a
stepping stone toward real world
applications, and we're
particularly interested in how
it can push in two specific
directions.
First, we're very interested in
this question of how agents can
learn to collaborate with each
other and with human players.
Recently we conducted the first
collaborative AI, Malmo
Collaborative AI Challenge,
where participants were tasked
to develop an agent that could
learn to collaborate in a
pig chase task.
So I can briefly show that here.
And this task we see two agents,
the blue and the red agent, that
are trying to catch a pig
together.
The pig is shown over here.
We can see this either in this
top-down view here or in this
first-person view that you see
over here.
So I can look around and see my
collaborator here.
And if this collaborator is able
to collaborate effectively, then
I can go and catch the pig right
here.
This game encapsulates some
really interesting challenges in
how we can infer intents of
other agents and how those
inferred intents or our beliefs
over their plans and their
strategy can inform the actions
that we or the AI agent should
take.
And the challenge task
participants, graduate student
teams participated from across
the world.
We had more than 80 teams
participating.
What was really interesting to
me was they came up with widely
different approaches to this
problem.
We're currently soliciting
feedback.
If you have any ideas on what
kind of tasks would be
interesting to conduct within
the Malmo platform, we would be
very interested to hear about
that.
The Malmo platform is very open
ended and supports a wide range
of research and tasks.
If you feel like trying it out,
it's available on GitHub.
Try it out today.